I actually don't get that many weird
emails or weird fan mails yeah I don't
know again I guess it's because I mostly
talk about anime and it's less about my
own personality I guess I don't know I
guess like one weird email ago recently
which wasn't even an email to me right
so someone used my email and pretended
to be me and emailed studio Wits right
okay okay I got the email here actually
the emailed studio went pretending to be
me as they use my email and I got a
notification from the official studio
which like you know you know like the
automatic notification that says hey
you've submitted this email to us okay
so the email reads hello I am anime
reviewer gig art I will make a request
of you many people want Eren and Mikasa
to have a relationship
Eren X Picasa I think if this happens
many people will enjoy the anime more
has to be a troll I would be pleased
with the development of events in this
direction I hope you will evaluate my
proposal I wish you good day man this
salad the email I said you contact me
for more so to figure out the logistics
logistics of Aaron X Mikasa oh you know
this is completely bypassed you say ah
my just go straight to win they just
emailed studio with who has no creative
control over how attack on sites is
gonna end anyway I really want I really
wish that like studio we took that email
seriously and like actually you hooked
up like you say I'm a being like so uh
you know do you make this a thing yeah
please make this a thing a season for
attack on Titan I'm ready I'm ready
hey you never know like none of us have
caught up on the manga
no no not like it might happen I feel
like I feel like it's a crime to and if
it does happen we can thank a certain ex
Mikasa is a thing I know I know who